welcome to this video playing kill 88
the skill 80 areas always good to play
as people with total idiotic names to be
perfectly frank but okay he's some
playing what is he playing the going
gambit that's not really that dangerous
and see what happens playing the
declined Goering gambit so known as the
cup of Blanca defense it's not terribly
exciting but black gets gets a decent
game quite easily check check home this
is just blundering a pawn for nothing he
has to take on c6 chest this is weird um
okay i'm just taking this yeah I guess
long castles with a temp Chang should be
good yeah get getting something light
for that sticky disconnection yeah that
kind of fits the demo ya got a weird
name yeah I'm playing a weird opening
blundering upon and then for fading due
to this connection yeah the chest
content is is really really a moderate
here but what can I do those games
happen as well and maybe you can have
some fun with it when you ask yourself
okay how is this game ending after two
minutes on a video yeah okay this was
ten points gifted to me but take them
thanks for watching